die Hälfte vom kaskaval Käse
echt jetzt mit einer größere Schüssel
ich kriege das schon hin
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein geniales Brotrezept
allerdings werde ich das Brot nicht
selber backen sondern ihr nehmt euch ein
schönes Brot und dickeres Baguette geht
auch so ein schönes französisches Brot
denn wir machen ein gefülltes Brot und
ich glaube so ein gefühltes Brot das
kann man auch alle möglichen Arten
machen als Pizzabrot man kann eine
flammkuchenfüllung machen ich mache das
ganze so ein bisschen inspiriert von es
gibt doch diese kleinen belegten
Brötchen mit Champignons wie heißen die
sind nicht diese Restaurant ich frage
euch
restaurantte Champignon wie heißen die
denn egal ihr Zuschauer ihr wisst es
bestimmt jedenfalls habe ich hier das
Brot außerdem brauche ich dann noch
etwas Olivenöl 200 g Champignons eine
Zwiebel und Knoblauchzehe jeweils 200g
Mozzarella und kafka-käse oder ihr nimmt
Gouda 400 g Schmand oder saure Sahne
Salz und Pfeffer und später noch etwas
Schnittlauch
das war's schon ich lege das Boot jetzt
aber allerdings noch zur Seite denn
zuerst einmal sind die Champignons dran
die werde ich jetzt einfach fein hacken
dann das Olivenöl erhitzen und ich werde
damit sie einfach schon mal ihre
Feuchtigkeit so ein bisschen verlieren
die Champignons anbraten
jetzt kann ich hier auch schon mal die
Zwiebel und Knoblauchzehen und dann
einfach fein hacken und mit dazugeben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann kann ich jetzt noch den Käse reiben
den Mozzarella den hacke ich fein
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt den Käse die
Champignonmasse darf kurz ein bisschen
abkühlen und jetzt nehme ich das Brot
und schneide hier ringsherum mit etwas
Rand
ein und Höhe des Brot aus und das Brot
innere das könnt ihr dann einfach
trocknen lassen und zum Beispiel
Semmelbrösel draus zubereiten
also so ein bisschen Brotkruste wollen
wir ja noch sehen
aber das meiste muss natürlich
ausgehöhlt werden
[Musik]
so sieht das Brot jetzt aus schön
ausgehöhlt aber ich habe noch genug Brot
übrig denn man will er sagt davon werden
jetzt nehme ich den Schmand da kommen
die Champignons rein
[Musik]
Mozzarella und die Hälfte vom
kaskawalkäse
echt jetzt mit einer größere Schüssel
ich kriege das schon hin
und das dann
und das hier dann mit Salz und Pfeffer
würzen und ein bisschen Schnittlauch
reinschneiden
man muss einfach so kleine Bewegungen
machen dann geht es mit der Rührschüssel
zack zack zack zack
[Musik]
dann kommt die Füllung jetzt hier ins
Brot
[Musik]
und wenn ihr jetzt ein bisschen was
übrig habt weil zum Beispiel die
Aushöhlung nicht groß genug ist ist gar
nicht schlimm das könnt ihr auch so
essen das schmeckt richtig gut
dann bisschen Käse drauf und ab damit in
den Backofen und das hier könnt ihr
wirklich wunderbar vorbereiten wenn ihr
mal Gäste erwartet oder Abendessen wollt
bereitet so vor und kurz vor dem Verzehr
dann einfach im Ofen backen
perfekt richtig perfekt
[Musik]
das Brot sieht richtig gut aus ich
schneide jetzt schon mal auf es ist
natürlich mega heiß wir müssen uns ganz
kurz abkühlen lassen und ich habe
natürlich nicht gedacht dass die Füllung
so flüssig wird vielleicht ein Ei rein
machen sondern ich wollte dass die sich
so mit dem Käse zieht deswegen habe ich
nicht gemacht
[Musik]
ich hole kurzen Teller und dann lasse
ich Murat und Dennis probieren heute
mach sie noch nicht wir trainieren jetzt
noch ganz hart
ja es wird ein richtig schöner Tanz
[Musik]
probieren kommen
müssen
zwei Zwerge
so dennis ist ein Kumpel von mir der ist
Grill Fetischist also krass heute ist
der da und der darf heute sowas
probieren ich dürfte übrigens schon mal
Kürbis probieren
ehrlich Gemüse
so und jetzt fängt ja bald wieder die
Größe so an ja da freue ich mich drauf
ja
aber dann im Garten
grillen so Wochenende
[Musik]
das riecht schon ein bisschen
kennst du kennst du
Iglo Schlemmerfilet kennst du das da gab
es Allahs glaube ich
stimmt und dann gab es aber auch das mit
mit Pilzen
aber da gabst du auch diese zwei Dinge
Bistro Baguette kennt jemand ach genau
daher kennen ja echt jetzt ohne Witz
mega alles alles was mit Käse verläuft
aber das schmeckt echt cool ein paar
Minuten
dann geht's auch nicht mehr gegessen
habe
doch gut
schmeckt wirklich wie das Bistro
Baguette nur in frisch
so eine Suppe dazu oder ein Salat und
dann fertig oder
leckeres Abendessen
beleidige ich mich auch dauern sag doch
was
der Kamera
sieht
genau dann könnt ihr das Rezept gerne
mal ausprobieren und vielleicht habt ihr
auch eine andere Geschmackskombination
die wir mal ausprobieren können ich
finde das kann man auch so auf die Art
so Pizza Füllung machen oder mit
Bolognese bestimmt auch richtig cool
viel Spaß dabei die Rezepte gibt es auch
Sallys blog.de oder in meiner App
macht's gut
[Musik]